all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
here with me Darius you and I over the
last couple of weeks have been talking a
lot about global liquidity and obviously
there's a lot of people on Twitter in
the mainstream media and even in the
Bitcoin world that focus on us-based
liquidity what's the FED doing what's
interest rates how's that impacting
inflation but if we go across the world
we can look at China and Japan as two
Asian countries that are very very
important when looking at Global
liquidity and so maybe what we could
start with is just China and kind of
what you're seeing there in that market
yeah absolutely so let me take a step
back and kind of help the audience
understand why we're even talking about
Chinese and Japan's liquidity cycles and
the reason for that being is because
they are both key contributors to our
Global liquidity proxy I think we spoke
about this last time we're on the show
in terms of the 42 macro Global
liquidity proxy which is the sum of the
global central bank balance sheet the
sum of global narrow money supply and
the sum of global FX reserves minus gold
and so China in terms of its
contributions to those aggregate
statistics is right around 20ish percent
and Japan's right around 15 so we have
to understand hey look if we're going to
be tracking Global liquidity and
ultimately trying to forecast
inflections in global liquidity we need
to go straight to the source of all
these major economies and so let's start
with the Chinese liquidity cycle I threw
a chart uh side one drawer do you think
of that up there where we show China's
liquidity and Market Cycles are
reflexively and increasingly linked and
so on the left chart I show our China
liquidity proxy which again is the sum
of those three measures but specifically
to the Chinese economy relative to the
Chinese stock market as you can see that
that relationship is tight and is
increasingly tight in recent cycles and
on the right chart we're just showing
that same Chinese liquidity proxy
relative to bitcoin and obviously that's
a pretty tight correlation uh in recent
Cycles as well so this is obviously
something we need to track and monitor
and ultimately forecast in order to
forecast uh you know kind of where
bitcoin price is going now talk a little
bit about China and kind of this
negative measurement that you've got
here right obviously liquidity ends up
being a huge huge huge piece of this but
when we look at liquidity impulse as an
example uh that's flip negative what is
that telling us yeah absolutely so yeah
what we're showing the second chart here
is again the top panel shows that China
liquidity proxy is a sum of 18.4
trillion dollars the second panel shows
China's Equity market cap at uh at about
plus 10 trillion dollars but I'd Focus
your eyes on that third panel where we
show with trailing free month momentum
study of that of our 42 macro China
liquidity proxy and as you can see you
know the big spikes in the bars you know
in recent months coming from those big
spikes down in Q4 of last year you know
we basically went from China to the
Chinese liquidity proxy draining about a
trillion dollars of liquidity on a
trolling three-month basis through
October to adding of about 1.5 trillion
dollars of liquidity to the global
liquidity Matrix to construct you know
in early q1 of this year uh that number
is kind of weighing in recent months and
now we're a little bit uh negative for
the second consecutive month here so
it's our view uh based on some of the
Dynamics we're kind of a you know you
know studying in the Chinese economy
specifically as it relates to the pboc's
reaction function to what has become a
disappointing
um you know kind of growth recovery in
China it's very unlikely that we see
another big massive wave of liquidity in
the very near term we think it's coming
because ultimately we we've been very
consistent in our view that when the
Chinese economy reopened from zero covet
that it was going to reopen back into
the structural liquidity trap that the
economy was mired in in 2019. I think a
lot of people forgot that where China's
economy was in 2019 prior to covet and
without the made large-scale fiscal
stimulus that they ultimately decided
not to implement they basically woke up
back into well it was a nightmare prior
to covet so and uh it's our view that
we're going to get another wave of
Chinese liquidity but based on some of
the recent measures that they've
implemented this morning uh they've uh
they cut the deposit rates by five to
ten basis points for the major Banks and
then they um they implemented a few
macro Prudential easing measures last
week it's not likely that we're going to
see another wave of liquidity on the
media term because they're going to want
to see how these things play out they're
not going to work so that liquidity is
coming but it just might not come for
another few months let's talk about the
public sector liquidity provision I
actually have no clue what the hell that
is explain what you're talking about
here and then why is that so important
to China and you think it's unlikely
that they're actually going to step in
yeah absolutely so that's a great
question you asked uh because I think a
lot of times certainly in the Twitter
sphere and you know the Lesser and less
so in institutional Finance but
certainly in kind of um the crypto
sphere and the Twitter sphere and
fintuit there's this sort of over big
overt fixation on Central Bank liquidity
and when you amalgamate and and it's a
fine thing to fixate on because you know
it tends to be the counter-cyclical
aspects of liquidity that we're all
trying to front run as it relates to
putting on big positions and asset
markets I.E Bitcoin et cetera but the
reality is
that's only half the battle when you sum
the central bank balance sheets and
their FX reserves minus gold it's
roughly about the same size of global
narrow money supply and so there's a
private sector liquidity component as
well that comes from commercial banks
that tends to be pro-cyclical whereas as
of the con the the liquidity that comes
from central banks tends to be
counter-cyclical and so when I say we're
trying to step up its public sector
liquidity provision I'm basically asking
is the public sector in China is the
Central Bank going to supply us
liquidity over the medium term and the
answer to that question is unlikely and
here's why on the left chart
in slide three here we showed the
trailing 10-year correlation to the year
over year rate of change in the Chinese
in the 42 macro China liquidity proxy
across a variety of different leading
indicators and so the blue bars for the
stock market the red line the red bars
are the real 10-year yield on your basis
the green bars are the Chinese women B
on a real effective exchange rate basis
the paint bars are the China's oec buys
the leading indicator the the blue bars
are a China's core CPI and then the um
purple bars of that employment rate and
what we find is when we test this on
various coincidence leads and lags is
that on a three to six month lead basis
the Chinese Equity Market is actually
the best leading indicator for the globe
photoshine and liquidity proxy and
here's why because the locals in the
Chinese market know when the pboc is
about the step is put on the gas or it's
about the step it's put on the brakes
and so right now if you look at the
chart on the right where we show each
the latest value for each of those
particular indicators on a z-score basis
the collection of bars on the left is a
trailing three year z-score that's a
cyclical look at it the trail the bars
on the right is a trailing 10-year
z-score it's a structural look at it and
in both instances the Chinese stock
market is declining and so it's telling
you that the global liquidity proxy in
China is probably going to be declining
over the next three to six months
because the locals don't believe that
we're going to get a wave of liquidity
out of pboc either through guidance Etc
when we look at China it's very clear
that you have this kind of link between
liquidity stocks Bitcoin in that
specific Market if we switch over to
Japan it seems like that same link still
exists is that many of the same drivers
or there's something different going on
in Japan
no no great question no it's all the
same drivers so we uh we so we run this
Global liquidity proxy so again our
Global liquidity proxy amalgamate
central bank balance sheets narrow money
supply and Global FX reserves minus
minus gold and then we do this for all
the major economies in the world so that
we can have a better handle on
forecasting you know global global
liquidity and so in Japan you know it's
less of a tight correlation with its own
stock market or it has become more tight
in recent Cycles but it's still pretty
tight correlation with the Bitcoin cycle
particularly in the last two and so you
know they're just telling us that hey
look you got to monitor Japanese
liquidity as well because again if we
look at the slot next slide where we
show Japanese liquidity impulse um being
currently neutral you know it's a big
deal and so what again what I'm showing
in this and slide here with the top
panel is the Japan's liquidity proxy
boj's balance sheet Japan neural money
supply blj uh FX reserves minus gold and
they skipped down two panels but back to
that third panel there where we show
that trailing three month momentum study
you look at that trunk the moment of
study look at the size of the bars
swings in the bars that we saw kind of
in late Q4 in the early q1 on a trolling
three-month impulse basis our 42 macro
Japan liquidity proxy was showing that
the Japanese economy was sapping 1.5
trillion dollars out of the global
liquidity Matrix you know kind of in
October of last year around the lows of
risk assets
by the time you got into q1 of this year
it was plus 2 trillion so we basically
had a three and a half trillion dollar
swing in the impulse that we the markets
were sort of I'm feeling from the
Japanese liquidity cycle well if you go
and look at it today it's flat and it's
been sort of flat to down in the last
three months and so this goes back to
the question we're sort of trying to ask
with our research which is you know the
next slide is Japan going to step up its
public sector liquidity provision over
the medium term and the answer to that
question is unlikely and the reason we
say it's unlikely because again we're
looking at various indicators of you
know kind of various leading indicators
of the Japanese liquidity cycle again
looking at the stock market change the
change in the real interest rate
changing and the the Yen on the real
effective exchange rate basis the the
growth cycle in Japan core inflation
cycle and then obviously the employment
cycle and when we look at those
different indicators on various leads
the inflation cycle the light blue bars
tend to have that have the highest
correlation in terms of projecting the
Japanese liquidity cycle and as we can
see in the right chart you know where we
show the z-scores of those selecting
indicators of the 42 macro Japan
liquidity proxy inflation is still very
high
um you know we look at on a trailing
three year z-score basis the 1.4 Sigma
on the trailing 10 year z-score basis is
a two Sigma and so it's suggesting that
hey look if these bars are pointed up
then the liquidity proxy should be
pointed down in Japan over the next
three to six months and that's
historically you know that's kind of
been the relationship so in summary you
know again what we're trying to do when
we look at these individual country
Composites to identify what their
respective liquidity proxies are moving
we're trying to you know get a real good
handle on what actually drives their
liquidity Cycles so that we can actually
forecast the global liquidity impulse
which you and I have talked about for
for over a month now is actually
currently negative and this is my
opinion one of the reasons why Bitcoin
is yet to kind of recover a tier to date
high so when you see these things
changing how long is the lag right it's
almost I think like kind of inputs
outputs and so when you see inputs
changing you know it's kind of going
into the machine right it's complex and
it's got to kind of work its way through
until we actually see uh kind of the
values changing or liquidity changing in
an output type manner what does that
timeline look like are we talking about
hey something happens on the input side
in a week later you can start to see the
impact on liquidity or kind of output or
is it six months like what is that
timeline yeah no that's a great question
so it varies by economy uh what we're
trying to do again in this analysis is
identify which are the particular
factors that give you the best lead time
to anticipating a change in the reaction
function for these respective central
banks or the change in the the reaction
function from the respective commercial
Banks and so you know specifically with
an economy in you know if there's an
economy that's you know much closer to
the bottom of its growth cycle I.E when
the purple bars are rising i.eu of the
unemployment rate Rising on a year of
your basis point Delta basis uh the
paint bars or towards the bottom of the
chart I.E the growth cycle is very low
Rel on a cyclical and structural basis
that's when the lead times are a lot
closer you know the central bank is much
more concerned about doing something now
whereas you have other factors like the
stock market that may be a leading
indicator rural interest rates in China
those are the number one and number two
leading indicators in China those
factors may not be as um sort of you
know they may not cause the same sort of
Trigger or sense of urgency out of the
pboc is as you know some other factors
would in a different economy so that's a
great question to ask you know it's not
perfect answer to the question but the
reality is this to my one I can see this
is certainly the best you know effort at
trying to actually understand these
Dynamics as opposed to just monitoring
liquidity on a coincident basis because
again you and I've talked about this
before you can't just look at a chart of
liquidity and saying liquidity is rising
that's not how you invest you invest by
looking at the chart of liquidity and
forecasting where it's going over the
medium term that's what we're trying to
do here with this analysis the last
question I have for you is around
guidance obviously uh here in the United
States everyone wants to know what is
Jerome Powell saying and then what is
dronepal doing and what they want to
really read into is what is he saying at
press conferences what is he saying in
interviews what is he saying uh in terms
of that forward-looking guidance now
guidance does not necessarily mean that
is what they're going to do as we saw
many people thought they were guiding
towards zero percent interest rates for
a very long time and said they jacked
them up to over five percent and
basically made many of the banks
insolvent before they had to step in and
backstop them what are we seeing from a
guidance standpoint in Asia and are
there things that we can take away that
help in terms of that 4 forward forecast
of where we think liquidity is going to
end up over the next maybe six to 12
months yeah great question so I'll start
with China specifically so you know one
funny thing that I don't think about the
average investor realizes about the pboc
is that the governor of the PPC does not
set monetary policy the folks in China
who set monetary policy or the pilot
world the standing committee in the
pillar Borough and there's guidance on
monetary policy actually hasn't changed
in years it's just been you know we're
going to maintain you know adequate
liquidity not we're going to give ample
liquidity or we're going to support the
economy we're going to do this it's just
going to maintain a flexible amount of
liquidity so you know in my opinion I
think that the lack of change in
guidance suggests that they're probably
not too freaked out about you know kind
of the disappointing nature of their uh
of their business cycle now that may
change you know I've obviously monitor
stuff on a daily basis uh 4 edition
macro but we have not seen any real
change in the actual policy guidance and
if anything go back to what we got in
March right because to me I think the
guidance in the monetary Authority is
sort of um underneath the guidance from
the broader pulip Bureau as it relates
to the economic targets they launched in
in March of this year uh the outgoing
Premier League
announced a five percent GDP Target that
was well below consensus they announced
the three percent budget deficits that
has a percent of GDP that was um tighter
than consensus was expecting and so what
I took from those signals is that this
is a Pula probe that does not want to
sort of you know go back to the wood in
terms of um you know chopping down or
creating a big you know sort of big
impulse growth impulse in China that's
due to kind of this investment boom
that's what they used to do right and
that's part of the reason they're in
this structural liquidity trap now is
they got an overhang of private sector
debt on on Chinese on Chinese balance
sheets that's kind of preventing you
know kind of a real rapid and you know
very you know forceful growth recovery
if you look at private sector debt in
China as a percent of GDP it's 220
percent and that compares to I want to
say 154 in the U.S and 167 in the
Eurozone so China and this is and China
is not a advanced economy with you know
the income that could support that level
of debt and so I think I think naturally
president G you know being kind of the
thoughtful leader that he's you know
proven to be in in recent in recent
episodes I think he's sort of trying to
avoid at all costs another kind of
large-scale stimulus program in China
that leads to another investment boom
that leads to an accumulation of even
more debt that puts them back to where
they are today which is an economy
that's struggling to grow because it's
too indebted I think that I think they
understand these uh these Dynamics
shifting to Japan
uh we so obviously we got a new governor
uh the bank of Japan Governor because we
will wait a couple months ago and he's
been very much kind of against the
speculation that the bank of Japan is
going to change your curve control
um yeah I've had the view that you know
part of the reason he was against it is
because if he says he's not against the
speculation then they're just going to
be more speculation so part of it which
could just be him sort of trying to tame
down Market expectations but there's
another situation that's in front of the
unfolding in the Japanese economy we
actually got data this morning uh for
specifically if you look at their wage
data because he's been sort of anchoring
on the wage data and the lag and how
much it's lagged core CPI data in Japan
going back to that chart six how much
it's lagged the movement core CPI as a
reason for the bank of Japan to not be
in a hurry to revise the to curve
control framework and if they're not in
a hurry to revise the UFO control
framework then It ultimately means that
we're probably not going to see as much
speculation against the yield curve
control framework that we saw in Q4 and
early q1 that really caused him to have
to defend that Peg that interest rate
Peg with rapid balance sheet expansion
and so um you know you put those two
things together it just looks like you
know we're not making the call that
liquidity is going to be as nasty as it
was in this in 2022 but we're certainly
making the call and have been for six
weeks now that liquidity is not
accelerating globally anymore and
obviously we have two very large
contributors to that to that um to that
construct uh moving in the wrong
direction Darius you've been all over
global liquidity now for weeks I really
appreciate it I always learned something
when we talk uh where can we send people
to find you on the internet or learn
more about 42 macro well I was gonna
joke say morganstanley.com because every
time I create a liquidity proxy it winds
up on their uh in their research but
that's neither
uh but no definitely come check us out
at 42macro.com this won't be the last
liquidity proxy we create that uh Finds
Its way across Global Wall Street
awesome thank you so much we'll
definitely do it again future
cheers man